The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's talk
about the important thoughts
for the week,
important concepts.
What do you have?
AUDIENCE: Energy method.
PROFESSOR: Energy method.
I'm going to say this
work energy theorem.
And from that, these turn out
to be our potential energies.
And this minus the work done
by the conservative forces
we call V2 minus V1.
That's the change in the
potential energy of the system.
So that's the work
energy theorem.
That's an important
one for the week.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Different
types of problems.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we did
several example problem
particularly emphasizing what?
AUDIENCE: With respect
to moving points?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, or points
that look like they're moving.
But you can use
special considerations
in calling them instantaneous
centers of rotation and things
like that, so summation of the
torques with respect to points
sometimes moving defined with
respect to ICRs, Instantaneous
Centers of Rotation,
and also moving points.
We definitely did some of that.
How about a third?
I'd say one more thing
that we got started on
is expressions-- 1/2 i, 1/2
omega dot h plus 1/2 mv, v dot
v, those kind of terms for this.
And for potential energy, if
it's purely mechanical devices,
we have two kinds
of potential energy
that we'll be dealing with.
And they are associated
with springs and gravity.
So that's the two
we'll deal with.
Are there others?
What's an example of a different
kind of potential energy
that you might run into?
AUDIENCE: Magnetic.
PROFESSOR: Magnetic
fields, yeah.
We can do work pulling something
out of a magnetic field.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Electric fields.
PROFESSOR: Electric
fields, sure.
But they do have
their complications.
So that's pretty
good for the week.
Now, we're going to
talk about this problem.
I'll give him a
chance to shoot it.
This is a good diagram of it.
You guys had a homework problem
that instead of a uniform rod,
you had a concentrated mass
on the end of a massless rod.
So this is almost
identical to that.
But we now have actual mass,
distributed mass, in the stick.
I've got a little demo
here, which will work,
works after a fashion.
Put a little tension
on these springs,
so now I've got my
cart on a spring.
The damping is
natural in the system,
comes from the wheels
and everything else.
I've got to get this
kind of close to the edge
so it'll work.
This thing has two natural
frequencies actually.
They're kind of hard
to isolate them.
There's one-- no, can't do it.
In one natural mode,
the thing swings forward
and moves forward together.
And in the other natural mode,
this'll go aft, that way,
while the other one's
going frontwards.
So let's see if I can--
that's higher frequency.
That's the motion of what's
called the second mode,
opposite.
And the first mode is
lower frequency than that.
It's hard to get a
perfect start to it.
So this is the kind of
motion we're talking about.
And we're going to
have you help me solve.
We want to obtain equations
of motion for this system.
And let's quickly run
through the exercise of-- you
can do this intuitively
first, it's so simple.
Plus you've already done it.
How many independent coordinates
does it take to do it?
Two, and how many rigid bodies
are there in this problem?
How many rigid bodies
in the problem?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: There's
gotta be two, right?
There's a block that
moves back and forth,
and there's this
rod that swings.
So the number of degrees of
freedom, we'll call it d,
is 6 times the number of bodies.
n is the number bodies minus
the number of constraints.
So this is 6 times 2
minus the constraints.
So we've got 12 minus c.
And you know the answers.
The answer, how many independent
coordinates to completely
describe this motion?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Just the two.
So you know the answer is two.
So that means you've
got to come up with 10,
a list of 10 of these things.
So let's see if you can write
down quickly your own list.
How would you eliminate through
coming up with constraints?
Write down the 10 constraints.
And I recommend you do it by
taking one body at a time.
So constraints on mass one, the
first block, what do you got?
AUDIENCE: y, y dot, and
y double dot equal 0.
PROFESSOR: OK, so that says
no motion in the y direction.
Because we're on rollers.
It's fixed that way,
so no motion in the y.
What else?
AUDIENCE: No motion in z.
PROFESSOR: No motion in z.
We're telling it it can't
come in and out of the board.
OK, any other translational
constraints on that one?
So no y or z translation.
And so that gives us
two constraints there.
What else on that body?
AUDIENCE: No rotations.
PROFESSOR: No rotations
in what direction?
AUDIENCE: x, y, or z.
PROFESSOR: In x, y, or z.
The thing can only translate,
so no x, y, z rotations.
That's three.
So that's a total of five.
But we have one left.
It's got to be able
to move in the x.
And how about M2?
What are the constraints
on the second one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So one at a time.
PROFESSOR: So omega which?
AUDIENCE: x and y.
PROFESSOR: No rotations
about which axes?
AUDIENCE: x and y.
PROFESSOR: So you're saying no
rotations of this about the x.
So it can't roll over.
About the y, it can't turn.
And about the z.
But we're doing this one.
So it's no spinning
about-- let's do it
in its body coordinates.
x1-- no spinning about x1.
No spinning about y1.
But can it rotate around z1?
OK, so for the second mass,
we have no x1, y1 rotations.
That's two.
And what about translations
on the second body?
Hmm?
AUDIENCE: No
translations x, y, and z.
PROFESSOR: No
So z, pretty obvious-- we're
not letting it do this.
But why can you argue there's
no translation in x and y?
AUDIENCE: Because it's
strictly rotation.
PROFESSOR: You say
it's strictly rotation.
AUDIENCE: For it to
translate [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so you're
saying translation
is strictly described
as parallel motion
of all points on it.
But where is it
constrained in x and y?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's
pinned to the cart.
And if you fix x, which
you're allowed to do,
a test you're allowed
to do, you have set this
as an independent coordinate.
If you fix it, this
point is fixed.
And you've constrained
it in x and y.
And if any point in the object
is constrained in x and y,
then all points are constrained
in x and y pure translation.
So we have in this one no
x, y, and z translations.
So that's three.
You add them up, you get 10.
OK, good.
Now, the next thing
I want you to do,
another key step in
doing problems like this,
is our free body diagrams.
And how many do you need?
As many as you
have rigid bodies.
You need one for
every rigid body.
So we got two rigid bodies.
Draw for me your free
body diagram for the cart
and for the rod.
OK, what group wants
to volunteer here,
tell me what I ought to do?
How about you guys in the back?
You're quite today.
So pick this first one.
AUDIENCE: You have the
spring force kx to the left.
PROFESSOR: kx.
AUDIENCE: Also bx dot.
PROFESSOR: bx dot.
AUDIENCE: Normal force up.
PROFESSOR: N.
AUDIENCE: You have M1g down,
and then the force of the rod
is down and to the right.
PROFESSOR: Oh, so you've made--
ahh, colinear with the rod?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
you're saying we've
got a vector force like
that, some F, right?
OK, how about a
little help on this.
Anybody have a different
result here for this one?
AUDIENCE: I broke up my
normal into two [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So you
have two pieces here?
So in what direction
do you draw them?
AUDIENCE: Reaction force of
the first failed reaction?
PROFESSOR: I guess
which coordinate system?
We need two coordinate systems
to define this problem.
AUDIENCE: Just in
the regular x, y.
PROFESSOR: So I've got
an inertial frame here.
And that gives me my X,
capital X, motion for this guy.
But we need, because if we
want to be able to moments
of inertia and things like that,
a coordinate system attached
to this rigid body, right?
So I've called it little x1,
y1, and it moves with the body.
OK, so you've picked
your two reaction
forces aligned with these two
or aligned in this system?
AUDIENCE: With the inertial.
PROFESSOR: OK, you've
done it this way.
So you're coming up
with a pair of forces
that have a piece like
this and a piece like that?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm talking
about for the wheels.
PROFESSOR: Oh, for the wheels.
Oh, OK.
You came up with
individual ones here?
Yeah, OK.
I'll call that N1 and N2.
And that's probably
an improvement.
Because that's what keeps
it from rolling over.
OK, that's true.
And what else?
So you've got a reaction
force here like that.
Can we improve on that?
AUDIENCE: You can break it up
into tangential and radial.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
but I understood.
The intention here was
it was drawn colinear
with the axis of the thing.
And that suggested
just that one part.
You could break that into a
horizontal in the master frame,
yeah.
But does anybody have
something different about that,
another way to do this?
Do you agree with this?
Is this correct?
Pardon?
You're treating
it like a string.
Is it a string?
Can that shaft
transmit shear forces?
Hmm?
If I grab this thing and
go left and right on it,
it's putting forces in that
direction perpendicular
to this.
So is it conceivable
that there are
forces on this
axle caused by that
that are in that direction
as well as that direction?
What do you think?
Because I can't make
an argument for sure
that would eliminate
either one of those.
Pretty sure there's
certainly a radial one,
because that's centripetal, and
there's got to be some of that.
But might there be some
in the other direction?
OK, so an improvement on this, a
necessary improvement, I think,
is that rather than just
one, we'd better have two.
And we're going to use
my system of naming
so that the answers I've
got here will work out.
I'm going to call that
one F2 and this one F1.
So now the rod is placing on
the cart two reaction forces
which you don't know.
Now, is that the complete
thing for the cart?
OK, now let's do this one.
Another group, tell me how to
do the second one, free body
diagram.
AUDIENCE: So you have
F1 and F2, but opposite.
PROFESSOR: Ahh, good point.
You've got an F2 this
way and an F1 like that,
is what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and
an Mg comes down.
PROFESSOR: And an Mg, yeah, M2g.
OK, good.
Real important point--
Newton's third law.
If you draw F1 and F2
here, those on that side
have to be equal and opposite
in order for all this
to work out without problems.
OK, those look
pretty good to me.
Now let's move on.
This is a complicated problem.
And to get a lot with it
in an hour is a challenge.
And you've done a bunch
of this problem already.
You did the one with
the particle on it.
So there's not a great
deal of difference here.
So I'm emphasizing a
few of the nuances.
What I now want to
do is to talk about,
how do we get equations of
motion for this problem?
How many will there
be to start with?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Got to get
two, two rigid bodies
and two degrees of freedom.
And you're going to end up--
it's the two degrees of freedom
that tell you you're going to
get two equations of motion
at the end.
OK, how many-- and I've
written three up there,
but it's not necessarily true.
You've been taught to this
point two different methods
for getting at these
equations of motion.
Somebody describe one for me.
How would you personally
go about this problem?
Just pick a method and
in words describe it.
And think of what you
did in the last homework.
AUDIENCE: Sum of external
force equals [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So sum of
external forces is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so on method
one here, I'll call it,
you're going to say sum
of the forces on what?
AUDIENCE: The rigid body.
PROFESSOR: So you've
got two bodies here.
So pick one.
Huh?
All right, so I'm going to
put this on M1 for sure.
That one is translating.
And you're going to
get an equation that
involves its x double dot.
It's got to be able to
move back and forth.
You're going to need
an equation like this.
So the sum of the external
forces on that mass
has got to be equal
to M1 times-- right?
And we can write an equation for
that in terms of this free body
diagram.
In the i direction,
you've got this.
You've got this.
You have the normal forces
gravity don't contribute.
And components of this and
this have to be added in.
You have to do an F2, probably
cosine theta, and an F1 sine
theta, and add them in.
Because they're the
external forces.
So you've got all these
summation of forces
on that side.
That gives you one equation.
This will give you an
equation for the motion
of the first mass.
And it'll have some
unknowns in it.
And what are they?
Describe them.
So you're going
to get a function
over here of a couple unknowns.
This is going to be a function
of what that you don't know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: F1 and
F2, and then also x
double dot and thetas and
theta dots and so forth,
all the variables
in the problem.
But these are two
unknowns you've
got to ultimately get rid of.
OK, what else are you
going to do in method one?
You've got to deal with
the second mass, right?
What would you do then?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So some of the
force is now on M2, for sure.
And that's going to give
you a couple equations.
What else do you
do in your method?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
torques about what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Have I named them?
Look at that diagram there.
So you're going to
do your torques, sum
of the torques, about A, OK?
And if you sum torques
about A, what are they?
I'll let you guys pursue that
a little bit, figure out,
what are the torques about
this point in this problem?
OK, what do you get?
Sum of the torques about A?
z is in which--
which positive z?
x, y, positive z coming
out of the board.
What produces torque about
this point in this problem?
Just what?
AUDIENCE: Gravity.
PROFESSOR: Just gravity.
And is it positive or negative?
And it's a component of
gravity perpendicular to this.
So it's probably sine theta
M2g sine theta in the minus.
So it's minus M2g L over 2--
you need the moment arm-- sine
theta in the k hat direction.
And that's going to be equal
to the angular dH, dT about A.
Sum of the torques, time
rate of change of the angular
momentum about A--
because that's what
you've chosen to work about.
And you always have this
term you have to check on.
OK, so that's the method.
This is method one.
I'll call this the tau
with respect to A method.
You have to write this equation.
You have two unknowns
that pop up in it.
You go to the second mass.
You write the F
equals ma for that,
and you're going to
get two equations.
If you do it in the
local coordinate system,
in the rotating one, you
get mass times acceleration
in the i direction.
You get F1 and a
component of gravity.
And in the j direction,
m2 acceleration in j,
you get F2 and a piece that's
acceleration of gravity.
You don't know this yet.
But you can find it.
You know how to find
those velocities now.
You've done it before.
So the velocity of
G with respect to O,
probably going to
have an X double
dot I hat plus something that
will be like L/2 theta dot,
and in what direction?
Hmm?
It's rotating like
this-- j hat, little j.
So there's your velocity.
You can take the time derivative
of that to get an acceleration,
X double dot-- that's not true.
Down here, you get
an X double dot.
In this one, you get two terms.
Because that's a rotating piece.
You get a centripetal
term and an Euler term
that come out of that.
So then now you know
velocities and accelerations.
You can put the
accelerations on this side.
You can solve this
first equation
for F1, second equation for F2.
You take those and
put them in here.
And you finally have one of
your equations of motion.
Down here, the external
torque only involves gravity.
So do your F1 and F2 appear--
do you have to mess with those
in this final equation or not?
This is the reason you use
point A. This equation does not
involve F1 or F2.
There's no moments
created by F1 and F2.
The stuff on the right hand
side is only kinematics and mass
moments of inertia.
This thing will give
you an i with respect--
you can think of this as
it's going to give you
an i with respect to
G theta double dot
plus some other terms.
And I want to talk about this.
Does this term go to 0?
Is the velocity of
A 0 in this problem?
No way.
And in what direction is it?
Horizontal, right,
capital I hat.
P, the momentum of
the second thing,
has these velocity components.
The P is equal to m times that.
And you have velocity
components in the I,
which is the same as vA.
But you have another velocity
component that's not the same.
So is that cross
product going to be 0?
No way.
You have to deal with that term.
It happens that you can
express H with respect
to A as H with respect
to G plus rG A cross P.
And you know P, because
you just found v. It's mv.
And r, rG A, is just
L over 2 j, little j,
which is from here to here.
It's L over 2 little--
no i, excuse me.
So that's r, L over 2 i.
So you can crank out
this cross product.
Then you have to take the
time derivative of this right
here, this whole thing.
Every time when you take the
time derivative of this part,
you will get a P. So
you get multiple pieces.
But one of them
will be minus that.
This thing creates a piece
that's exactly minus that,
and they'll cancel.
But you've got to go
through the cranking it out
till you get to that point.
OK, that's one
method of doing it.
Let's talk briefly
about a second method.
What is the other way to go
about doing this problem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's method three.
We're going to hurry
so I can get to it.
What's a second way to do
this problem, a close relative
of the first way?
But I want you to have
all these different ways
of doing it in your tool kit.
Because some problems are
easy, more easily done.
There's another way than this.
This is perfectly appropriate
for this type of problem.
If the problem we were
doing involved this,
would you do this method?
What would you do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, can't
use energy yet.
That's next week.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ahh, right.
So the second
method is basically
this is the same, this piece.
But the second part--
and this is the same,
sum of the forces about M2.
You do both of those forces.
You do sum forces
for sure, M1 and M2.
But the third step is you
do sum of torques about g.
If you sum torques
about g, which is here,
what appears in the sum torques?
Does Mg contribute?
No, what are the
external torques about g?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: F2, L/2,
positive F2 L/2 k.
So that equation,
summing torques about g,
will give you an F2 L/2 k.
And now you've got
that unknown popping up
in your torque equation.
And you know that it also pops
up in these two equations.
Because we solved them.
So now why does this method
have a slight advantage
over this method?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, you don't
get F2 or F1 popping up
in your torque equation.
You immediately get to
the answer for that one.
So it's a little more efficient.
So is there a way
to get directly
at the two equations
we're after?
The second equation we get
from this torque thing.
The first equation we
get from resolving this.
This is a mass times--
M1 X double dot.
And you get this
function of F1 and F2.
And you have to substitute
in for these F1's
and F2's until you
finally get that equation.
So that's kind of tedious.
So is there a way to get
directly at this without having
to mess with F1 and F2 at all?
And that's what is the key
to what you're talking about.
Let's look at something here.
Let's do the vector sum
of the forces on M1.
We get an F. Let's look
at our free body diagram,
F2j plus F1i minus kx minus
bx dot and a minus M1g.
Well, those are-- well,
we'll put them in there,
at least throw them in there.
This is in my capital J plus
N1 plus N2 capital J hat here.
Is that all the forces, all the
vector forces in that problem?
Did I miss anything?
I've got spring, the
dashpot, the forces
caused by the rod, gravity,
and the normal forces.
OK, and we could figure
out the component of this,
the sum of the forces on M1
in the capital X direction.
We could figure
that out from-- this
has component in that direction.
It just involves thetas.
These go away, then.
You don't have to deal with
this stuff in the x equation.
But there's our sum of the
forces on the first body.
Let's do the sum of the
forces on the second body.
What are they?
AUDIENCE: Gravity.
PROFESSOR: OK, so you've
got a minus M2g on it.
And what else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: But with
opposite sign, right?
F2 little j minus F1 little
i, and anything else?
Nothing, right?
Let's add the two together.
Oh, and this one has got to
be equal to the mass, M1,
times the acceleration,
the x component I plus M1
acceleration in the-- I
can't write over here-- ay
in the capital J hat direction.
That gives us mass
times acceleration,
is what all the sums of
the forces is equal to.
The same thing here-- this is
equal to the little mass, M2,
times its acceleration.
And it'll have components
in the-- this is mass 2.
And it'll have components we
can put in the I hat direction,
and plus M2 acceleration 2--
maybe I'll do it like this.
a2y, and this is
in the j direction.
And those two things
we can add together.
And so if I add them together,
and I put M1 plus M2 times--
I'll just call it the
total acceleration.
Well, I don't want to do that.
I don't want to say this.
I'm hurrying because
we're running out of time.
M1 times its acceleration
times M2 plus its acceleration
is equal to-- and now we sum
up everything on the right hand
side.
And the key thing
that happens here
is what happens at F1 and F2?
AUDIENCE: Drop out.
PROFESSOR: They
completely drop out.
So on the right hand side, it's
not a function of F1 and F2.
The equating of motion that
we were trying to get here
was just in the I direction.
That's all we need
for that big cart.
So if we go down
here and extract
the I component of this total
sum, it'll be an equation.
It'll involve M1 and M2.
And it'll have cosines and
sines and thetas and things like
that, but no F1's, no F2's.
You will get directly to this,
the final result that you got
here where you had to
go in and substitute
in for F1's and F2's.
So it'll get it to you directly.
What do you need to
solve it, though?
You need to know the
acceleration of mass 1.
You know that.
That's trivial.
You need to know the
acceleration of mass 2.
And that you did
by taking the time
derivatives of these terms.
You know the acceleration
of that mass.
So you need that expression.
And you plug that in here.
And everything else in the
right hand side you know.
It's kx dot, bx dot, minus Mg,
M1g minus M2g, and so forth.
All the rest of
the stuff is known.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does this give you
three equations of motion?
PROFESSOR: Well, it
gives you two equations.
At this point, you'd break
this into capital I and capital
J. The one in the capital
J direction is equal to 0.
There's no motion
in that direction
for the main mass, the cart.
There's only motion in the
inertial frame x direction.
So that's all.
This is a vector equation.
It has two pieces to it, I and
J. The J is a static equation.
The I is your dynamic one.
And it's this one that you would
have found in this problem,
but without ever having
to solve for F1 and F2.
But you do have to go out
and find the acceleration
of both masses.
Mass times acceleration, what
this is really saying-- this
is what you asked
about the system.
This is sort of the
system approach.
If you think of this
whole thing as a system,
draw a box around it, the
sum of the external forces
on the system is
equal to the mass,
the total mass, times actually
the acceleration of the center
of mass of the system.
But this acceleration
times the center
of mass of the system, you can
break this into two pieces.
It is this term plus this term.
And then that's
the total system.
And all you have
to put on this side
is the summation of
the external forces.
But the external forces are
not-- the internal forces
don't count.
They're not part of the system.
So you only have to
put the external forces
on it-- Mg's springs, dashpots,
normal forces, outside forces,
the only ones that go over here.
The reason we don't
usually think of doing this
is because when you
think about the system,
you write it as the acceleration
of the center of mass.
But you have to
realize that you can
get that expression as the
sum of the parts, the sum
of each bit times
its acceleration,
and sum them all up,
is the same answer
as the sum of the masses
times the acceleration
of the center of mass
of the whole system.
So we've still got
a couple of minutes.
Last hour, I ran over, and
we couldn't get to this.
So there is, in a way, yet
another thing you can do.
And that's think of the
thing as a whole system.
And sometimes that'll
give you an equation
without having to use
F1, without having
to solve for internal
forces-- pretty cool.
All right, so
questions, thoughts?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is it safe
to say that if we
have two more rigid bodies,
we should probably consider it
as a whole system [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, I can't
generalize on that.
I haven't done enough problems
like that myself to even
have enough experience
to know just how often is
that going to help you out.
This one, there's a
pretty obvious equation
that you're going to write in
this direction on that mass.
It's constrained to a single
motion and a single coordinate
you're assigning to it.
And probably in
cases like that where
you can isolate one
of the rigid bodies,
there might be some advantage
in doing something like this.
AUDIENCE: --more
difficult to figure out
what the accelerations
for both rigid bodies was,
then it would be
better [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this
one, all of these methods
you're going to end up having
to compute the velocities
and accelerations of each piece.
And if you've got
that information,
you may as well
use it if there's
something to be gained by
doing a clever step like this.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What confuses me is
that method one, method three,
there's no-- so you
said there's going
to be two things in motion.
But why is it--
PROFESSOR: So this,
this method three,
this shows you a different
way to get that equation.
You still need this.
AUDIENCE: Oh, this is
just for the first--
PROFESSOR: This is a clever way
to get just this first equation
down.
You still need a
second equation.
And you still are
going to have to--
and then you don't want to
have to mess with F1 and F2.
So we've just found
a way to never have
to mess with F1 and F2
in at least this problem.
And that is get
the first equation
by using this trick,
the system equation.
And it's a sum
forces expression.
And then the second equation you
need is this moment equation.
And you have two choices,
about G or about A.
And which one can you
do it without having
to find F1 and F2?
I'm doing it about
A. So there's a way
that you can do
this whole problem
and never have to address
what F1 and F2 are.
And that's kind of a combination
of these two pieces here.
The traditional way, the
textbook way, you open it up,
the textbook will
teach you this one.
And it'll teach you about
A and teach you about G.
But you don't often run
into-- there's sometimes
a direct way of doing it
without finding the F1 and F2.
Unfortunately,
there are thousands
of problems in the world.
And it's a little hard to say
in advance what method to use
and what's going to
work the easiest.
But there's some insight.
There's some
generalizations that you
can get from looking at things
in these different ways.
If you have forces
at a pivot point,
taking the moments
of the pivot point,
unknowns of the pivot
point, taking the moments
about that point will
get rid of them for you.
That's the one generalization
that you can usually
take to the bank.
But beyond that-- and if
the thing's unconstrained.
So if it's fixed axis
rotation, then you
want to use about the
axis of fixed axis.
This is a moving axis.
But it is still rotating about
a fixed point that's moving.
There's still some
advantage of doing this.
If it's the eraser
problem, this thing,
where you have no fixed
points of rotation--
if you take a body, and
you do this with it,
where is it spinning about?
Where is its axis of rotation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Always, right?
That you can take to the bank.
If there's no forced
pivot, bodies on their own
only rotate about their centers
of gravity, centers of mass.
And then when you
have free bodies that
don't have constraints that
are forcing them to move
with respect to something,
if there's no constraints,
then you want to take the
torques about G for sure.
Good, all right, see
you guys next Tuesday.